[Music]
and now he nation please welcome
president of basketball operations
[Music]
hello
[Music]
thank you everybody and I just want to
let everybody know that last night was
an incredible celebration there was a
lot of love a lot of fun a lot of
nonsense we had all of the families
there and I just want to thank everybody
for coming out tonight I do like the
score so we got to keep it that way
that's for you by the way we're your
brothers Dwyane Wade you know merely
merely never ever wanted to be
considered anything else other than the
best he wanted to be unique he wanted to
separate himself from the pack he did
that and what he did more than anything
else in this city and for this franchise
and for all of his loyal fans and for
all you kids out there that want to be
who he is who he became is he has left
footprints for others to follow
and he has left and the biggest
footprint for us is going to be right
here now so if I could get Gabby okay
and Zaire okay Dada we go
is that something
it's gonna happen right now number three
is gonna be imprinted forever okay
up in those rafters
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the newest the icon
the man is hanging from that ceiling in
a way that he will never be forgotten
Duane it's all yours man
[Applause]
thank you thank you thank you thank you
at first I want to thank the man above
for everything he's done for my family
and me
I want to start by telling you guys a
quick story now
the story takes place in March of 2003
in Minneapolis at the same time in
Milwaukee there was an old old coach
running on a treadmill getting ready to
watch his imma mater
the Kentucky Wildcats take on the
unknown School Marquette University
the Kentucky Wildcats what a best team
had caught his basketball they had a 26
game winning streak going into the game
as this old coast washed his former
Wildcats of course he expected victory
instead he washed his Wildcats get blown
apart by an unknown player from an
unknown school at the end of the game
this Blair had 29 points 11 rebounds 11
assists and 4 blocks it was at that time
only the fourth triple-double in NCAA
history now I may be making this part up
but I believe that's the moment this old
coach said damn who is that player we
need him now let's fast for three months
June 26 2003 the NBA draft from Radio
City Music Hall in New York
the late commissioner David Stern comes
out an analysis with the fifth pick in
the NBA Draft the Miami he selects
Dwyane Wade for Marquette University
as you know I was that unknown player
who led Marquette to victory during
March Madness three months earlier at
the drive when I went backstage I
remember sitting on the stool putting no
headphones preparing for my first
interview with the Miami Heat
I was introduced to you and did not
heard cheers when I finished the
interview once again all I heard was the
crowd cheering this time even louder
at the moment I felt your love I later
learned that Miami was broadcast to my
interview right here in this arena and I
was up there on that Jumbotron and that
was the first of many moments we were
share together your appreciation and
love has never left me if there is one
word one feeling that I want to convey
to you tonight it is gratitude
beginning with my first coach my father
do anyways senior pops you told me the
fundamentals of basketball you drilled
them into me over and over and over
again in doing so you weren't simply
teaching me about the game of basketball
you would teach me about the game of
life the discipline the dedication the
patience took quote-on-quote
get it right I am forever grateful to my
high school coach Jack Fitzgerald who
was an extension of my father
coach you demanded that I become a
leader and learn how to lead you drove
home a message you drove home a message
that I learned from my father the
importance of team success that my
individual success is only achieved when
there is team success Gary out was my
high school assistant coach he told me
the importance of being on time
the importance of sacrifice doing
whatever it takes to be and do my best
coach Adams was preparing me to be a
professional my head coach at Marquette
Tom Crean he changed my life
he offered me a scholarship to Marquette
knowing I might possibly be academically
ineligible to play and it turns out I
was and he made sure to oversee my
academic progress in my freshman year
going into my sophomore season I found
out that I was about to become a father
that my mother was returning to prison
and coach Coach Crean became more than
just a coach to me he became my life
line on and off the court
he helped me discover a place within
myself that I didn't even know existed
when I mumbled the words coach I came he
challenged me he pushed me and he showed
me that I could Stan Van Gundy was
amazing with me
Stan thank you for trusting me your
trust allow me to become the player I
became when I joined the team I was told
I would play point guard a position I
never really played before it was in the
middle of the season we were in Seattle
getting ready to play the super Sonics
when I went to coach and told him I felt
constricted and I wanted to play more
freely about the few minutes of
back-and-forth he said okay I knew this
was my opportunity to show not only
stand but everyone in his organization
how good I can be and from that game on
I never look back now it's time for that
old coach again Pat Riley
Pass in-store Denari basketball
knowledge integrity and passion for the
game has helped this organization
achieve greatness Pat teaches each of us
in his organization the importance of
accountability first to ourselves and
then to each teammate past philosophy of
being the hardest-working best condition
most professional toughest meanest
nastiest team in the NBA is the mantra I
live by for 16 years and the mantra I
will Catina live by in my second act my
last head coach Bo
[Music]
slow begin is my development to coach my
rookie season when SPO became our head
coach in the beginning we had a lot of
ups and downs but through adversity we
grew when I left for Chicago our
personal relationship became even
stronger we spoke a lot not as player
and coach but his friends our guards
were down we were two men with great
respect for each other we spoke about
life family now how the game went well
how many minutes I played it was at that
time we were able to return to the trust
that had been established disposability
to stay in the integrity of what he
knows to be right for the team has made
such a difference in me it has enabled
me to be more balanced and not be thrown
off by what others may say tonight I
think about and think all the teammates
I'll play with I wouldn't be standing
here without any of you to point out a
few my college teammates Travis döner
Robert Jackson Scott married
Terry Sanders Todd talents and Steve
Novak and so many others I think about I
think about what it took for us to build
a team that went to the Final Four
it took hard work it took a belief in
one another
it took each of us being a little
bullheaded it took all of us buying into
what Coach was teaching us in the NBA I
had teammates such as Caron Butler who
taught me about treating everyone with
respect people behind the scenes that
don't get the credit also matter neglect
no one
Lamar Odom helped me understand that
this game would take me from the highest
of highs to the lowest of lows in an
instant through alonzo I learned the
meaning of preparation
that every moment was a moment to get
better what it was in a walkthrough
shoot around practice or games though
brought the same intensity and focus
once Shaq joined our team and said I'm
gonna bring a championship to Miami I
promise I heard you and I believed you
your bold predictions accelerated my
growth and took my game to the next
level
your leadership gave me confidence to be
the player and man that I was destined
to be Chris Bosh
Chris bus
it simplifies as a man as a player the
best of what this world has to offer as
an opponent you were fierce but as a
teammate your greatness made our
greatness possible
LeBron James LeBron James greatness it
made me want to be greater we developed
the relationship very early in my MBA
careers and looked at each other as
brothers every time we played against
one another's opponents I knew it was
gonna be a battle we always brought out
the best in each other and it would be
no different as teammates we challenged
each other daily to be greater for our
team and for ourselves
ud
[Applause]
you dig
from the first moment we met you treated
me like family I would not be standing
up here as a three-time champion without
you I definitely wouldn't have as much
money in my bank account if you ain't
take all those files over the years that
should have been mine my boy we all know
we don't get to choose our families but
I got to choose you thank you for being
my brother I love you
team wait chef rich Dre Chantelle
Kellyanne
Simone Maya Alicia Bob Metellus so many
others thank you for believing in me
thank you for your sacrifice dedication
and commitment to my vision to my family
and for always doing what it takes no
matter what my late agent Harry Thomas
and my business manager Lisa Joseph
Metellus they would care for me like I
was a very own child thank you for
pushing me to want more for myself thank
you for always being real and for not
giving up on me when iversity hit thank
you for showing me that my vision wasn't
too big
thank you both for loving me my mother
Joe Linda wait is my hero
mom you have always shown me you have
always told me they even through the
darkest of times when you feel stuck
when you feel like life has given up on
you through faith perseverance and
dedication you will overcome whatever
obstacles are in your way my sister -
Gil
thank you for putting your life on hold
to make sure that a young crusty booger
nose kid had a chance to fulfill his
calling thank you for putting me in the
right environment and seeing my worth I
love you forever thank you for you to my
sisters Dianna Keisha Moriah my brothers
Lester
Demetrius Academies thank you all for
your love and protection throughout my
life to my children as I air Zaya
davi on Xavier and Kavya James thank you
so much for teaching me that life is
bigger than just me my greatest
responsibility is being a parent it is
also my most rewarding I am so proud to
be your father
I hope I make you proud to call me Dad
- my wife gap
thank you for coming into my life and
show me that life could be different do
you I learned that life is really what
you make it thank you for all
experiences we share thank you for those
Twitter rants when I wouldn't get the
calls out deserves
thank you for calling me out when I
wasn't on top of my game and I'm not
just talking about basketball I'm
speaking about life thank you for loving
me thank you for pushing me out of my
comfort zone
and show me down worthy of so much more
thank you my love for showing me that
I'm worthy of you
before concluding once again I want to
express my gratitude this time to the
Harrison family from the beginning when
I became a part of this organization you
made it clear that I became a part of
your family
you guys treated me as such thank you
for everything you've done for me and
everything you do for the city
a special special thank you to everyone
in his organization behind the scenes
that don't get the credit to the legal
division financial division arena
division sales and service division
business strategy and market division
our training style equipment managers
and ball boys over the years thank you
for your hard work and commitment to
this organization my teammates and me
in clothing in the words of one of the
greatest players to ever played a game
of basketball
my friend the late Kobe Bryant
Koby said the most important thing is to
try to inspire others so they can be
great in whatever they choose to do I
hope I've inspired all of you thank you
for making me a part of your legacy
please know you are a huge part of my
god bless you all
he nation
I love you
the Heat fans let's hear it before too
[Music]
[Applause]